[Music]
a little low
here's the thunder baby oh sh
oh my god david foster baby it's here it
is here and there she has company uh she
is not alone we get some uh cosmic
cosmic help going on here yes i love it
i dig
well
let's jump into it welcome back to new
rock stars the latest thor love and
thunder trailer included shots of a
mysterious chamber with golden statues
pointing to various well-known cosmic
entities who look very much like the
living tribunal the watcher death eon
and infinity who are these [ __ ] why
are they in love and thunder and will
they take a form beyond a statue what
the [ __ ] flick
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's weekly marvel reaction show
in um two weeks from now this will turn
into our miss marvel after show right
now the biggest story in marvel this
week is thor love and thunder and uh it
looks to be changing the hierarchy of
cosmic authorities in the mcu uh we're
gonna go
way into that this episode who these
gods of the gods are and uh well before
we do i'm eric voss here with me is mt
mt how you doing i'm doing good man i am
so glad to finally see more jane foster
thor cause like the teaser trailer
wasn't enough for me i needed to see her
in action and did you see how that
hammer just like shot out different
pieces that was freaking dope that was
dope yes that was incredible uh i love
how it can uh break apart into different
pieces and then come back together right
so such a cool detail uh how it's like
it's never fully
uh fully fused back together it stays in
a broken state right i dig it it's so
cool taco my tt that wasn't good ideas
well let's uh let's talk about uh this
interesting shot of all the gods to the
gods here uh
but before we get into that it is your
last chance to grab our doctor strange
latest obsession shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com this limited
edition shirt features artwork inspired
by doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and it's about to be kick
through the star portal for good to make
room for a new latest obsession shirt
coming soon so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to check out all of
our awesome merch options and to support
the channel mt what question are we
talking about this week all right we
gotta ask who are these five cosmic
entities revealed in this new four love
and thunder trailer my friend yeah the
trailer shows the mighty thor jane
foster arriving in this mysterious
chamber she's riding a pegasus she's
coming through a fiery rift that seems
to open and close with her arrival into
this room with these five golden statues
visible in frame there may be more out
of frame these are just the ones that we
see the clearest one is the three-faced
hooded head of the living tribunal none
of these have been confirmed yet by the
way this is but this one is obviously
him you know the marvel character really
looks like this uh and this is its third
mcu appearance in the past year after
being the first alternate dimension
doctor strange in america chavez passed
through in multiverse of madness and
appearing as a severed head statue in
the void and loki and we should note
empty the living tribunal has now made
more actual mcu cameos than kang has
it's true and we also have the mention
of the living tribunal and doctor
strange one as well so like he's
everywhere
absolutely kang has never been spoken in
live action in the mcu the tribunal has
we don't see the k word of the mcu yet
not yet
not yet
uh now the living tribunal is the cosmic
entity that oversees all natural law
across the multiverse kind of like a
chief justice and the infinity gauntlet
comics infinity war and end game were
based on uh other entities actually
appeal to the living tribunal to try to
punish thanos who's snapping away half
of all life and the living tribunal
acquits thanos but saying that thanos
never actually broke any natural laws um
now if you look slightly beyond the
living right people in this shot it
looks like the watcher uh we know him
from the internet what if voiced
we want some more of them he's got that
huge bald head the high collar cape it's
got to be him now remember watchers also
showed up in guardians volume two right
the watchers oversee the multiverse but
are supposed to never interfere but of
course uh interfered and what if in the
comics you want to i believe interferes
to warn the fantastic four about
galactus right uh so he does
all natural laws are meant to be broken
and then on the left side of screen
closest to us a hooded skull most likely
death or lady death uh some were saying
red skull but red skull's teeth are not
that exposed there's a bit more flesh
covering his skull this is just a bare
skull it's death right and death of
course is a representation of death and
marvel lore like really many of these
entities are embodiments of abstract
concepts um death is the figure that
thanos in the comics went on that stone
quest four uh in an attempt to woo death
and actually deadpool later hooks up
with uh lady death at one point big fan
of death that deadpool fun pairing yep
um now behind death and this shot is a
weirdo named eon we're pretty sure this
is eon eon is the embodiment of time or
at least associated with time he has
this immense gross anatomy he stores
infinite knowledge from throughout
history uh really it's just one of these
trippy things from 70s captain marvel
comics after jim starlin saw a grease
stain on a garbage bag on a street
corner and found its shape fascinating
that is the true origin the genesis of
eon in the marvel comics it was a trap
story's like that it's like eons
probably would have never had likely
would have never happened if it wasn't
for that weird circumstance i love that
yeah definitely not
and then behind eon is a bald female
figure that we're pretty sure is
infinity infinity is a sister to
eternity she's another all-powerful
cosmic entity who really is vaguely
defined but in the mcu the art on the
wall of the temple of morag and
guardian's volume one is depict uh it
depicted four cosmic entities with the
infinity stones we had death eternity
infinity and entropy so the mcu history
may suggest that infinity could have
been the source of the infinity stones
and today i know you've made a lot of
theories uh
wading into these waters yes oh yeah
yeah i i definitely feel like infinity
is definitely the source of the infinity
stones in the mcu and whereas eternity
her brother is probably just the
representation of the actual physical
universe like the actual space so like
them two together yeah make the mcu but
yeah for sure now um in the comics these
five in particular are not really
grouped in any specific five-member
lineup the way that the illuminati are
you know known in known grouping but
they they're all from the same tier of
cosmic overseers who just tend to show
up whenever the multiverse is being
threatened or when any one being rises
too quickly to god tier and threatens
their hierarchy
now there are actually some disputes
over the exact power hierarchy in marvel
lore but uh pretty much universally
accepted is at the top of that hierarchy
is an entity known as the one above all
in the comics the one above all is
usually unseen has often uh been likened
with jack kirby himself
uh but in the mcu someone said that the
one above all of the mcu might just be
kevin feige it's meant to be a kind of a
meta thing we never i would love to see
it
yeah
um but really right beneath the one
above all is often considered to be the
living tribunal because as the ultimate
legal authority the living tribunal is
the one all other entities appeal to the
living tribunal's verdict is final you
can't be overruled by anyone else
but it can be avoided or subverted or
sidestepped via loopholes that kind of
thing but you know once you appeal the
living tribunal there is no higher power
to go to um
so why are these five appearing in thor
love and thunder well my theory is that
these entities are the mcu's version of
those who sit above and shadow at least
when it comes to their relationship to
the asgardians uh those who sit above
and shadow are the really the gods to
odin and the thor
and all the other asgardians they set
the rules of ragnarok they empower
mjolnir in the mcu we've you might have
heard reference to the term all fathers
you know some people say that's
connected to odin but uh whenever they
pray to all fathers uh to give them
strength uh like heimdall did to get
strength for uh to blast hulk back to
earth he might have been praying to
these figures uh and these figures just
take different forms to different groups
who pray to them um but it doesn't seem
like this is where mjolnir is getting
its magic because we see jane in this
chamber harnessing lightning
through that hammer um so this movie
seems to be giving us a sense of the
broader hierarchy in general of the mcu
and the way i see is we have multiple
tiers i'm just gonna run down the tiers
that seem to be uh taking shape here we
have tier one the base based here
which is where we see humans other
mortals
you can include enhanced individuals but
humans who can die even if you have
soldier serum or whatever um
tier two would be asgardians and
eternals and olympians the slow aging
demigods whom humans have worshiped as
gods they can die they just age very
slowly um then you have tier three which
are the abstract gods who have large
corporeal bodies who have to use avatars
to do their bidding so i would group
bastier
torret ahmet khanshu maybe zeus
we know within the pantheon of gods in
olympus and thor love and thunder some
of them are just bigger than the others
and they seem to have like a different
kind of status than the other normal
sized gods who sit around them if
mephisto ever shows up i would assume
abisto would be on this tier just
because mephisto tends to use avatars or
champions to do his bidding uh like
ghost rider etc um
now i think these guys might be on the
same tier as celestials but i actually
think celestials might be on their own
tier tier four just because they seem to
be in their a different class than like
i would agree
um
and then uh tier five would be these
cosmic entities were now seen in the 311
thunder trailer the the watchers the
living tribunal the death eon infinity
eternity the abstract concept beings um
and then uh the living tribunal i
actually think is gonna be who are shem
is now appealing to after eternal since
you know cersei was a tier two being
killed tiamut who is a higher tier being
that being a violation that airship must
go to a higher tier to appeal to that
being the living tribunal is my theory
for that but i think above all of these
would be a final tier tier six where the
one where the one above all resides and
i just like the idea of there being six
of them six being a harmonic number in
nature aligns with the six infinity
stones everything being hexagonal shaped
etc etc and i think in this movie only
these tier five cosmic entities can
decide when a being can change tear move
up or down between tears and that's why
they have that relationship with jane
foster because when jane powers up in
the lady thor she is jumping a tear and
that's a totally different evolution
from other times we've seen people
suddenly get empowered whether it's a
human suddenly getting super soldier
serum or or with jennifer walters game
of radiation or becoming an avatar uh to
a god the way mark specter and uh and
layla did so i think these five beings
decided that jane should become thor to
temporarily help the other gods in this
gore crisis and i think we may not see
their giant cgi forms in this movie they
may just be voices coming from statues
but either way i think that's going to
be their function this movie mt i want
to hear your thoughts i really love that
you connected them with uh those who sit
above and shadow because like they've
been teased ever since the first thor
movie um when uh we i think there's an
object in odin's vault that does tease
those who sit above and shadow so like
it would be great if like they were the
mcu's uh translation of that it would
make a lot of sense because they seem to
be like like you said these like
overseers of the marvel universe so like
it'd be dope if like like you said jane
foster does power up herself here and
like does get her powers of thor here
because it seems like a very rea it
reminds me about the shazam uh where
shazam gets his powers that little uh
area in the the dc movie so like i'm
getting like very shazami vibes there so
like i could totally see that being a
place where um she gets those powers but
i i have a feeling me personally i i
feel like this little chamber or
wherever she is
is
like this where she'll end up getting
a cosmic awareness because um in the
marvel comics um like the cosmic
awareness is basically your ability to
just
know things that like important things
in the co in the cosmos in like uh eon
himself uh i believe he uh he gives
quasar cosmic awareness because eon is
the one who gives quasar his cosmic
bands his quantum bands rather um and so
i think i think all of these characters
were deaf eon um you know
the watcher living tribunal um all of
them all have something in common and
like it's this lit this cosmic awareness
so i feel like maybe jane foster like
the one thing that will give her a
one-up on her predecessor thor is that
she is able to just know when things are
happening in different parts of the
universe and just head to them in an mcu
tie-in book that tied into an infinity
war jane foster was actually able to
sense the snap happening without
actually being at the location of the
snap or even being associated with any
of the avengers at the time so like she
has a degree of cosmic awareness within
her already within the mcu which is kind
of crazy um
it's probably due to her experience with
the ether in thor of the dark world um
so yeah i think that this could be like
her having a deeper cosmic awareness she
her getting those powers from these
entities i think it'd be really cool uh
but yeah i really do i love this idea of
those who sit above in shadow and like
them being the ones who sit above in
shadow like being the ones that god's
worship because it's really cool to see
who the gods of worship in this movie
for sure
yeah and you touched on something that
we brought up before this idea that jane
had exposure to the ether in thor the
dark world right uh and i think that
might be the explanation behind her
cancer i mean you know we talked about
if infinity is the source of the
infinity stones she might have taken
particular pity on jane foster felt
guilty for something she created uh you
know leading to like no human was
probably meant to make contact with the
reality stone right like right so maybe
eternity just had some kind of
uh pity for especially when you consider
that like you know an end game in the
time heist rocket both extracted the uh
the ether from her and then cap had to
put it back in her
when the when the time heist ended and
we never really saw that which it's
pretty messed up and you can imagine
these gods being like
you know what no this uh this this
individual deserves redemption so let's
you know maybe that could have been the
reason why eternity or excuse me
infinity could have lobbied the other
four and said no let's do this for her
that would be really cool because like
we do know in thor too that like she was
sort of called towards the ether so like
that's not really her fault like the
ether sort of just screwed over like
they either pulled her into the ether
dimension like come here like you're
coming here and i want to go into you so
like i would i could totally see
infinity being like yeah all right she
really she literally saved the universe
in thor 2. let's let's throw her bone
and like you know give her these powers
yeah i can totally see that that's a
good idea
yeah um well we're going to talk about
the future of jane foster the future of
mjolnir in the future of the thor title
as we move on with this episode before
we get to that we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
thank you to bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode so even when stripped of
his robes before pantheon of gods thor
has some confidence and confidence can
take you pretty far in life and in the
bedroom and that's where blue chew comes
in bluetooth is the unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but
chewable tablets in a fraction of the
cost you can plan ahead or be ready for
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple you sign up by
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting line
at the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are
made in the usa and prepared to ship
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help you we've got
a special deal for our listeners to try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code marvel at checkout just pay the
five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
blue chief for sponsoring the show we
also want to thank stance for sponsoring
this episode we love us some stance
socks around uh the new rockstars office
they fit great they have cool designs
made with brands like the marvel pixar
mlb nba and simpsons brands they even
have a new line inspired by fortnite let
everyone know you're glad no build mode
is here stance is branching out beyond
socks to bring color and comfort and
creativity from toe to head with the
launch of a new active apparel line
check out stance's super soft line of
sweatpants shirts hoodies hats and more
now available in a full range of fits
prints fabrics and fun embrace a life of
superior comfort and creative expression
with everyday active apparel that is
truly stitched different stance's
philosophy is that you should never have
to sacrifice your own individual style
for the sake of comfort and now you
don't have to whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town stance now
delivers its signature softness and
creativity and a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head stances
got you covered head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use the promo code marvel at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different and we want to
thank athletic greens for sponsoring
this episode are you looking for a
simple way to get an all-in-one
nutritional insurance with one scoop of
ag-1 you are absorbing 75 high-quality
vitamins minerals whole foods superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right this special blend
of ingredients supports your gut health
and nervous system and your immune
system our very own tommy bechdel
started drinking their ag-1 every
morning and he's been loving it he says
it tastes great it's easy to drink first
thing in the morning ag-1 supports
mental clarity and alertness as well as
better sleep quality and recovery and
for every purchase they donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to kids in need including no kid
hungry here in the us reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop of ag one in a cup of water every
day to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com marvel again that's
athleticgreens.com
marvel to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance all right mt uh
after this thor love and thunder trailer
drop taika watiti uh clarified something
a lot of people were wondering about
what's next for jane foster what's next
for mjolnir and he explained that jane
foster might not be the permanent
torchbearer for mjolnir by the end of
this film i'm going to quote him
directly and do my best uh horrible
impression that i can do it i think a
lot of fans are going uh gonna
potentially assume oh okay this is
passing on the torch i'm not privy to
the plans marvel has for the future and
i don't think that's the case
bro that was amazing that was amazing
that was not shitty at all that was like
i was impressed i was like is he
actually here
that's weird
that's pretty cool a little weak i don't
think that's a little thin i liked it i
i give it a 9.5 out of 10.
but what i love about this quote and
thank you by the way too it's very kind
of you to say um
it sounds like with ct is doing some
expectation management right uh he
doesn't want people to go ahead and
start like uh planning on jane foster
being the permanent thor i don't think
he wants to trap natalie portman into
that not to say natalie portman can't
come back as jane foster in the future
um but it seems like he's indicating hey
the future of the thor title is uh way
more wide open than we expect so i want
to ask you who do you think is going to
be the mcu thor at the end of this movie
i
i think that they're leaning towards
jane foster i think that that'll be the
case um because like hey like it happens
in the comics but also i i just feel
like
having jane foster in this movie as thor
and then not giving her the title and
like just having like thor odinson just
keep the title it doesn't seem like it
it would seem like a kind of a waste of
time and like kind of a waste of natalie
portman and the character of jane foster
thor and i feel like so many people
especially women want to see um jane
foster take over this title and sort of
just like be be an avenger and like help
like help the avengers in the in the in
the mcu proper so i think that in like
and also considering that like the
posters say the one and only thor
i have a feeling that jane foster will
end up um just fully taking on this
title while thor himself just tries to
find himself like his mother wanted him
to in an endgame because like that's the
true measure of the of a hero
apparently to uh frigga so i think that
four wants to go on this journey of
self-discovery while the universe is
protected by jane foster but what do you
think i mean i guess like my question is
do a lot of women need to see natalie
portman as jane is that something that
like all women are clamoring for i know
there are a lot of women who like this
arc i'm excited for this arc too i would
say like if you were to survey a lot of
women i think they'd say we
there are other like interesting female
characters that we'd love to explore
without dealing with this like deal they
need to be super buff and doing a chris
hemsworth impression for a movie you
know like uh what's so great about this
jane foster storyline
is it uh it's it's less about her being
thor and more about just like exploring
jane exploring what she's going through
uh and i think
i think where this movie will end up is
kind of in this open-ended place where
jane can at times be worthy and be thor
and and take on that mantle but also
thor can still be thor and he doesn't
have to be de-powered to still be who he
is and i think bringing other worthy
candidates in the mix including as we
saw in loki frog can show us
i think
i kind of want at the end of this movie
to have beta ray bill carrying
stormbreaker and then yes
beta ray bill to be a version of thor
that goes forward in the future uh but i
i don't think unless like chris
hemsworth is done
and he gets killed off in this movie
which i don't i don't think that's gonna
be the case like i think hemsworth has
found a sweet spot he's found a
character that he loves playing um like
i i know that i think it's gonna be a
fun conflict in this movie of who gets
to be thor and uh scene to scene to
scene uh and it's gonna be like a fun
exchange and kind of an arm wrestling
between these characters i'm very
excited to see that um but i don't think
it's gonna be the same thing uh that
like the fact that sam wilson is now
captain america right like that was like
a permanent change and now going forward
we call sam wilson captain america right
uh i don't think we're going to see that
kind of handoff in this movie and i
think that's what what tt is saying
interesting
um like i would really love for
for jane to stay but like i can totally
see jane not saying at the same time and
like and possibly seeing beta ray bill
um taking up the the mantle like as the
new thor like i was like i mean they're
completely left out of left field like
surprise like oh my god it's battery
bill everyone like has been clamoring
for this character for forever but yeah
no i could totally see that but also i
have this um idea where i feel like at
the end of this jane foster could get
the mantle and we could see four
transitioning into loki season two and
like being plucked out of this universe
for a little bit and uh having jane
foster just doing her thing but um but
no i could totally see your i'm sorry
you think we'd see
hemsworth show up in loki season two it
was the most watched disney plus uh
marvel title as well yeah and like
everyone loves loki so like after loki
died in in infinity war we see like this
different variant come over and have a
whole story in this separate tva type of
universe so like if if jane foster does
end up being the next door or the mantle
floor gets passed on to whoever then i
can see the marvel cinematic universe
being like all right we're not gonna use
thor in this main universe for a while
because the mantle has been taken over
so let's just have some fun and put thor
with this loki variant and like have
them reunited with thor having this big
loki tattoo on his back and having like
a really awkward exchange with loki
being like i thought you were dead i got
a tattoo i'm back
for nothing the biggest trick of all
time you got me um so yeah i think it'd
be really fun to see chris hemsworth
being funny in low-key season two but
that's just yeah i want to see these two
together on screen again i think that's
one thing i'm missing from the thor love
and thunder footage is loki you know
i've loved all these uh screenshots that
people are putting together of like when
loki suddenly gets disrobed in loki
episode one and when now thor is getting
his clothes flipped off like
as guardians they uh they bring a lot to
the table their always show is always in
season with these guys yeah they they if
they're they're they're the peak they're
peak uh they're peak beings that i'll
tell you that much for sure like they've
got muscles on muscles for sure
for sure we'll leave it there for this
episode of inside marble as a
mt now and i retreat to our spank banks
our many great options over at
newrockstarsbirch.com follow me at ea
basketball empty that mastertainment
don't follow him all the way to wearing
headed decks because you may not like
what you say
you better be a little frightened
oh my god
oh my god
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast if you don't uh already
feel disgusted by
everything i've just said but i want to
thank you all so much for listening yes
and watching and we'll see you next week
bye everybody
you